you
[Music]
well good afternoon everybody thanks for
coming today
appreciate it I was pretty everyone
appreciate everyone's patience today one
of the things I wanted to mention that
really resonated with me was the
following quote failure from small
mistakes to huge miss calculations is a
necessary and critical part of our child
of our children's development these
words really resonated well with me at
the time when I first read them because
it was also at the time we were going
through our own growth mindset effort
here at the company and I was dealing
with the terrible teens of my own kids
at home and so trying to be able to
figure out when should I let my son miss
the bus how many times should I let him
miss the bus and then what do we need to
do to really make sure that he's going
to grow up to be a successful child and
a successful adult our speakers today
her book really helped me and my wife in
this effort I'd like to welcome educator
writer and speaker Jessica Leahy today
as an English writer and a tea and an
English English and writing teacher the
calmness for the New York Times and
correspondent for the Atlantic which I
have a subscription recommend you all
should as well she's also author of the
best-selling book the gift of failure
how how the best parents learn and let
go so their children can succeed I'm
hopeful that I can be one of those
parents in some lifetime at this point
but I like to introduce Jess in the
welcome here at Microsoft today thank
you so so much for coming today I
understand there's competing talks today
so I really really appreciate the
attendance and today I'm gonna be
getting into some of the details of sort
of how I ended up here and my work but
one of the things you should keep in
mind is that my son Finnegan if you've
read my book my son Finn is sort of a
centerpiece of the book and he is here
today so and he's happy to answer
questions occasionally so he's also
acting as my assistant today so anyway
why I'm here so I have been a teacher
for 20 years I've taught every grade
from 6 to 12th grade I was a Latin and
English and writing teacher and
currently am an English teacher in an
inpatient drug and alcohol rehab for
kids in Vermont so my work is actually
heading
more in the direction of addiction
prevention that's what my next book is
about preventing addiction in
adolescents by starting when they're
very very small and so that's what I'm
really excited to sort of segue into
those conversations but what this book
really has been about for me is so after
20 years of teaching I think when I
first started and by the way I didn't
never intended to be a teacher I thought
I was going to be a juvenile attorney I
went to law school and studied education
law and juvenile law I was going to work
in juvenile courts and then I was asked
to go teach a class and I came home that
first day and my husband took one look
at me and he said are you are you even
gonna finish law school because it was
so obvious that I was completely sunk as
a teacher as that was what I was going
to be and that's what I've been ever
since so I finished law school but I
went straight into teaching and have
been doing that my entire adult career
and most of my career actually has my
heart lies with middle school because
middle school is this incredible place
where my job is to watch kids screw up
all day long and I get to especially
where I most recently taught middle
school it was really really small hours
our school area our classrooms and our
locker rooms so my office was sort of
right outside one of the locker rooms
and so I would hear these kids out there
talking and I would go out there and
mill about with them and I you know I'd
say something like so sweetie
today is the sixth day you've forgotten
everything so what are you gonna do what
are we gonna do how can I help you come
up with a strategy for day seven what's
your plan for day seven and we get to
talking about some possible ways to use
this plan book how he's using it now how
he's even using his plan book by the way
what we can do differently maybe for day
seven and what started to happen more
and more often was you know we'd get
into this great learning opportunity and
he was listening and I was helping him
you know through the things he tried and
things that hadn't worked and oh let's
try this instead and then all of a
sudden you know
about ten years ago what started to
happen was the the door would open and
the parent would run through the door
which like here's your homework here it
is and the kid would say well that's my
strategy I mean why do I need to come up
with anything else because all I have to
do is text my parents and they'll bring
it to me at school and from my
perspective that was frustrating and
that was sort of was the beginning of
what I also started to notice as a real
divide between teachers and parents it
used to be I started when I first
started teaching I sort of thought oh
it's gonna be beautiful it's gonna be me
and the parents and the kids and it's
gonna be all about the education and
we'll grade each other's hair and talk
about the learning and that's that's not
where we are right now especially in
really high anxiety high pressure
schools increasingly we have this like
adversarial relationship between parents
and teachers which you know as a teacher
that just doesn't work because there's
plenty of research to show that the the
better the relationship between home and
school the more productive the kid can
be the better inform the parents feel
and the better the kid does so creating
a schism between home and school
benefits no one
and so I was couldn't then I was
concerned about that and then I became
acquainted with Dan Pink's work
obviously it's it's out there in terms
of his TED talk and his book Drive and
knew that a lot of the things we were
doing to get kids to engage whether
that's behaviorally or with their
schoolwork these things like sticker
charts and things like you know money
for grades and stuff like that I knew
some reading Dan Pink's work and the
work of someone else that I'll talk
about in a minute that that doesn't work
that it feels like it works because it
works in the short term but over the
long term we undermine kids motivation
to learn so that's sort of really
well-trod territory and I'll go into the
research in a second but what was even
more concerning was that I was starting
to
feel and I wasn't sure this is
prewriting the book and doing all the
research that not only were we
undermining kids motivation we were
undermining their actual ability to
learn that when we intervene when we run
through the door with the homework when
we offer money for grades when we use
sticker charts for kids when we rely on
the grade itself as the reward as I'll
get into that what we actually do is
make it so that our kids are less able
to learn they are less teachable and
that was devastating I had a student who
wrote a paper for me explaining that her
obsession with being perfect had made
her so obsessed with her grades and her
scores and looking good in front of me
and looking good in front of her
classmates that she had she had lost
interest in learning it was no longer
about that for her she was so obsessed
with the points in the grades that
learning was now as she said beside the
point which again devastating for me
because I taught her for three years I
was her advisor and at the time hold
your hats here because at the time I was
teaching Latin and English and writing
sixth grade Latin seventh grade Latin
eighth grade Latin seventh grade writing
eighth grade writing seventh grade
English in eighth grade English all at
the same time and I was her advisor so
there were days where I had her for
three classes and an advisory periods so
I knew her really well and this is a
girl who would come into my classroom in
sixth grade just so excited to learn she
couldn't wait mrs. Lahey was late what
are we gonna learn today and now she's
telling me in eighth grade that she no
longer cares about learning so somewhere
along the way we screwed her up we did
that to her between and at first of
course from my very high horse as a
teacher I was like her parents have done
that to her it's not me I'm fantastic
but her parents are screwing up my
ability to teach her in the way this is
me and my noble profession and education
and learning and they you people are
screwing it up for me unfortunately then
I had these children of my own I have
one who's a freshman in college right
now
and Finnegan who Finn who is in eighth
grade thank you I saw that look and at
the time I realized as angry as I wanted
to be at you people for screwing this up
for me I was doing the exact same thing
to my own children Finn there believe me
there are lots and lots of stories that
I'm not allowed to tell but the
authorized ones I am allowed to tell and
one of the authorized stories is about
the day I found out that when he was 9
that Finn didn't know how to tie his own
shoes I found out because he hadn't been
attending PE class because he had been
wearing his balloon he's been wearing
his brothers boots to school which
wouldn't be that big of a deal except
for the fact that his brothers five
years older than him so they weren't
really boots so much as they were like
leg casts because they went over and he
couldn't bend in D and so he couldn't do
PE and so he came on the same day
actually that I got that sa from the
student about the fact that she no
longer cared about learning I was trying
to get to the bottom of this sneaker
situation where are the sneakers why
aren't you wearing the sneakers to
school and I came to find out that the
only sneakers he had access to were his
sneakers with laces and he wouldn't wear
those because he didn't know how to tie
them and he had been too ashamed to tell
me and he'd been too ashamed to tell
anyone else
and so I I had to come to terms with the
fact that I had done that you know your
kid is little and they first get manual
dexterity and tying shoes is hard so you
sit down you think oh this is gonna be
great totally instagram-worthy right
you're gonna work on the shoes and he's
gonna learn how to tie your shoes and
everyone's gonna be so proud except it's
really stressful and it's really hard
some kids get manual dexterity later
than others and getting the laces just
right is really really hard and so that
first day I didn't I didn't want to see
him frustrated so I did it for him but
just that one time except the next day
we were in rush and it's faster if I do
it and so I did it that day but just
that
and now I'm in a situation when I first
started looking at writing this book
he's nine and he's so humiliated about
the fact that he can't tie his own shoes
that he's just avoiding it by wearing
boots all the time so that's where I was
as pissed off as I wanted to be at you
people I had to realize I am you people
so off the high horse I came and I
started researching how these extrinsic
motivators motivators that come from
outside of us like grades and points and
scores and money and rewards and all
that kind of stuff how that undermines
motivation and how that undermines their
ability to learn and luckily I was I'm
also an education journalist and so I
was writing for the Atlantic in the New
York Times and I published an article at
the Atlantic on a research study that
was looking at how over parents and kids
affects their their trajectory in school
and that sort of started this whole deep
dive for me okay so let's start at the
beginning Dan pink TED talk drive based
a lot of his work on another book by
Edward DC and by the way if you go to
Jessica Lake accom under speaking
there's a big button that says download
speaking bibliography and it has every
book I'm gonna mention every YouTube
video every resource that I might even
touch on is all there so just the Leahy
com big button download speaking
bibliography under speaking okay Dan
pink so Dan pink based a lot of his work
the early work on Edward DC why we do
what we do the science of self
motivation Edward DC found and along the
way there what we have come to sort of
realizes there's 40 years a really great
research on the effects of extrinsic
motivators not only 40 years of really
good research there's there's metadata
there's studies of that 40 years of
research to show one really clear thing
that when we lure people when we give
people extrinsic motivators in order to
get them to learn we undermine their
interest in learning from my perspective
as a teacher it means if you want your
child
do not want to learn math over the long
term the fastest best waited to to sort
of kill that office to pay them for
their math grades what's really
interesting about this research though
is there's also research showing that
when we offer extrinsic motivators to
get kids to do stuff we also mess with
their creativity so that's a problem
because as a teacher
from my perspective education should be
a long-term creative endeavor and if
we're screwing around with it from my
perspective as with grades I mean those
are the tools I have and then from the
home perspective with money for grades
and that kind of thing we're in big
trouble the creativity stuff is really
interesting when you offer an artist
when you try to control an artist's
output or offer them rewards offer them
trophies or money or whatever for their
output it turns out that you can create
a situation where the artist or the
child the child in kindergarten who's
being offered rewards for painting in
kindergarten
whether it's dealt their child it
doesn't matter they will spend less time
on it they will be less personally
invested and the work itself will be
less create creative it turns out there
are these creativity experts and you can
though they can look at this and assess
this the other problem is this and I'm
going to point directly at sticker
charts mainly because one of the
questions I got originally before I even
came here today thank you I'm three for
passing those along it was about sticker
charts one of the problems with sticker
charts is this often we give stickers we
use sticker charts in schools to shape
behavior there are a bunch of programs
out there that do this there's classdojo
there's sticker charts at home have you
good at school today if so you get a big
sticker schools of character schools
that are really really deeply concerned
with character education don't use
sticker charts because what sticker
charts teach children to do is to be
good only when people are watching right
because what is the benefit of doing the
right thing unless someone is there to
give you the sticker if we are teaching
children to only be good when someone is
why
that's a problem because schools of
character one of the things that they do
is they talk about making sure kids know
the right making kids sure kids do the
right and doing the right not just when
people are watching but when it's just
the right thing to do I am reminded when
I talk about this stuff I'm often
reminded of a admissions counselor at
Dartmouth she's no longer there but when
she was there she wrote this lovely
op-ed for the New York Times about who
she would be who they admitted to
Dartmouth and why and she talked very
specifically about this one kid that
they decided to admit to Dartmouth
because he had a letter of
recommendation from the janitor than one
of the groundskeepers at his high school
and the groundskeeper said this is the
kind of kid that picks up trash on
campus when no one is watching and this
woman at Dartmouth said that's what we
want for our community so that sort of
stuff is really important now when I
talk about extrinsic motivators I want
to clarify there's different kinds
there's the kinds that are perceived as
positive like money for grades or stuff
for grades when I go around usually when
I go around to schools I talked to the
kids during the day and then they do
professional development with the
teachers in the afternoon and then I
talked to the parents in the evening and
I do this little thing with the kids
what I say to them is all teachers and
staff close your eyes now raise your
hand kids if you get paid for grades
around depending on the school district
around fifteen percent or so between
fifteen and twenty percent raise their
hands then I say put your hands down now
raise your hands if you get anything in
return for grades stuff in return for
grades and it goes up a little bit maybe
like 20 25 percent of the hands go up
depending on the school district and
then I have them put their hands down
and I make sure the teachers and the
staff all have their eyes closed make
them promise and then I say think about
this really carefully before you do it
but raise your hands if you really truly
believe that your parents love you more
when you perform well in school versus
when you don't
in middle school among middle school
kids about 80% of the hands go up and
among high school kids about 90% of the
hands go up so extrinsic motivators can
be loved they can be us loving our kids
more showing more love when they're
giving us those grades that we want from
them and no I'm not an idiot I know you
can't we we just react emotionally
differently when kids are doing poorly
versus when kids are doing well because
we're worried we want our kids to do
well in school
but what I'm talking about here more is
giving them the idea that we really
ensure they love them more when they
give us those letters we want from them
there can also be negative extrinsic
motivators and what I'm talking about
perception and those can be things like
you know you are grounded if you have
anything less than a b-minus average or
you know we are going to take away your
devices if you have less than a whatever
and the prayer and then there's a there
are a couple that you wouldn't think of
as extrinsic motivators but they are
let's say for example oh if someone
could log on to a computer anytime they
want and see their children's grades
like 10 20 30 40 50 times a day heck
just keep it up on the desktop and just
hit refresh all day long and it sounds
like I'm making a joke here and sort of
be using hyperbole but I'm not because
from our perspective as school
administrators and teachers we see how
many times you log in we know mainly we
talk about you because we are concerned
as teachers and administrators that when
you're logging on constantly on the
computer that you are not having
channels of communication with your
child may not be ideal because it looks
like the parents from my perspective
anyway the parents that log on the most
tend to be the ones who don't really
have really good open channels to
connect or of communication with their
children now there's another kind of
extrinsic motivator that you also may
not think about and that's tracking your
kids on their phones
and that's called surveillance as is
using the portal so and I'm not saying
we can't use any of these things I'm
just saying that we have to be aware of
them because if their effect is to
undermine motivation and learning as
I'll get to in a second then we're doing
our kids a disservice if we're relying
on those things in order to shape their
behavior again with experiencing
motivators one of the things we have to
keep in mind is in the short term they
work great
they are fantastic if you want a boost
motivation if you want to get sort of
get the kid off the starting block then
extrinsic motivators can work great if
you want to offer your kid you know a
nice sparkly pair of soccer shorts for
going to that first soccer practice then
great do that but you can't have that be
your strategy moving forward because it
will undermine their motivation and
their investment over time so here's
what we do want we want intrinsic
motivation again I am NOT an idiot I
don't think that if you just do the
things I'm gonna tell you about in a
second that your kid will be like
quadratic formula I can handle it are
you so excited but you can up the
chances that they will be engaged for
the sake of the learning itself instead
of for the sake of those numbers and
points and grades ok if we're really
lucky the highest form of intrinsic
motivation is this little something
called flow me high csikszentmihalyi
bout flow it's that state where you're
doing something that's difficult it's
not too easy it's not too hard but it's
difficult enough to really engage your
body or your mind for me it's
cross-country skiing you know it's hard
for me it's a difficult thing and I'm
not doing it because I'm gonna you know
win a race I am never going to win a
race but it's it's challenging it's
challenging to my mind and to my body
and so time and space falls away for
some people it's music you know that
sort of the classic flow state is often
described as like jazz where you're so
engaged in it the time and space falls
away you don't get flow when you're
being extrinsic ly motivated forced to
do something for the sake of something
else and if you think about extrinsic
motivators for a second when I was young
used to have this thing where if we read
a certain amount of the summer Pizza Hut
would give us coupons for pizza think
about that for just a second what's the
most valuable thing in that equation
books or the pizza well the pizza is the
reward I mean if we really wanted to
make books be the valuable thing we
would give kids books for eating a lot
of pizza right okay
intrinsic motivation Edward DC talks
about intrinsic motivation in his book
at why we do what we do the science of
self motivation it requires three things
number one it requires autonomy which is
kind of like independence but a little
different it has to do with control over
the details when for those of you in the
room with toddlers you know full well
you do not say it's cold would you like
to wear a hat today no no no no you say
it's cold do you want to wear the red
hat or the blue hat right because then
you're getting some buy-in because they
get to have a little autonomy over that
decision in the town where we live we
don't we're not big enough to I live in
a very small town in New Hampshire we're
not big enough to have our own high
school so kids have school choice and
parents just worry and worry and worry
over the choice because it's you know
it's such an important decision and it
is but I always come back with well but
if you let your kid choose then you're
automatically getting more buy-in
especially since the high schools we
have to choose from are all pretty darn
good and if you get buy-in from your kid
you're more likely to have buy-in and
that's autonomy control over the details
so autonomy number one number two
competence which I'm so sorry to tell
your parents it's not the same thing as
confidence confidence we are really good
at as parents we are not so good at and
still incompetence and I'll come back to
that in a minute
and finally connection connection when I
talk to teachers doing professional
development is this I could spend 90
minutes just talking about connection
because it has to do with relevance and
this thing called self epic
see and getting rid of learned
helplessness and all this stuff that's
really fun if your kids have teachers
that make a subject to come alive in a
way that makes them think I could go out
into the world and do stuff with this
information then please start sending
thank-you notes because that's really
where the secret sauce is with education
for parents it's really pretty simple
and I'll come back to that at the end
all right autonomy the in the book I
talk about the work of Wendy Greuel neck
she does research on the way we pal we
parent affects kids motivation and
learning and one of the cool experience
experiments she did was this she had
mother infant pears and I'm sorry duds
it just happened to be mothers in this
experiment mother infant pears came to
her lab and she designed a task for the
kids that was engaging and exciting
something they would want to do but
something that was a little bit hard for
them she wanted it to be challenging on
purpose because she really was
interested not whether or not the kid
could you know how they did the task but
how they reacted when they got
frustrated and then just the
instructions she gave the parents were
really quite generic on purpose be there
with your child while they complete this
task because she wanted that to be open
to interpretation some of the parents
were there while the child completed the
task they let the child have control
over how the task was completed if the
kid got frustrated they were there to be
supportive
they were what's called autonomy
supportive they were there and
supportive of the child's autonomy but
they didn't take over and those were
referred to again as autonomy supportive
parents and then some of the other
parents and I'm sure we don't know any
of these we're all over the task they
told the kid how to do it and where to
do it and what order to do the steps and
laid out the steps very clearly first do
this then do this and by the way that
behavior was amplified when she told the
parents that their child's work would be
evaluated by other parents after the
after the experiment that went through
the roof so these parents over here were
called directive Wendy also uses the
word
trolling but I'll stick with directive
because I might piss you off more later
and so I'm gonna stick with the nice
words now directive autonomy supportive
directive here's where it gets
interesting then she has the children
come back with the parents this time
she separates the mothers from the
children and gives the children another
task that's engaging exciting something
they want to do but again a little bit
frustrating the children of the autonomy
supportive parents got excited about the
task and engaged in the task and got
started and got going and got frustrated
but we're able to kind of take a breath
look at it another way think about the
instructions again and sort of finish
finish almost all of them finish the
task the children of the directive or
controlling parents they got into the
task got excited about the task got
frustrated and almost all of them cried
and gave up they were missing whatever
emotional wherewithal they needed in
order to sort of stick with it and be
okay with being frustrated being okay
with being frustrated sort of is at the
heart of this whole equation because
kids who can't be frustrated and we all
know what these kids look like right you
take them to their first gymnastics
class and they can't do a cartwheel
perfectly and they're like I'm out
that's it forget it I'll never be able
to do it ever and that's really hard to
get past and and that I'll talk a little
bit about that before we're done and how
to get over that but when you can't be
frustrated there's a lot of learning
that can't happen too and the way that
these directive parents are you know
feeding the kid information and saying
okay first do this second do this and
not wanting to see our kids get
frustrated that is so natural I hate
seeing my kids get frustrated I hate
seeing my students get frustrated I have
the answers it would be so great if I
just gave them the information and then
no one has to be frustrated ever and
frankly it makes me look like a better
teacher because now my students are
getting the right answer
whether or not they really understand
the information very well that's a whole
other question
why do I care so much well when kids are
really really little a kid who cries and
gives up and can't can't stick with
something that's frustrating as a parent
but eventually they're gonna end up in
my classroom or a classroom and this is
where the rubber really hits the road
because what ends up happening is kids
who can't be frustrated can't learn as
well I would always rather have a
perfectly average and I use the word
perfectly on purpose a perfectly average
child of average intelligence I would
much rather have a kid that's of average
intelligence but who can be frustrated
then a kid who is brilliant beyond
measure but gives up the second they
feel like they maybe can't do something
right because that kid who can be
frustrated is more teachable and here's
why one of the most powerful teaching
tools I have as a teacher there - I talk
about frequently one of them I talk
about mostly with teachers but the one I
talked about with parents is this one
called desirable difficulties it was
it's there's a fantastic book that it's
on the bibliography that came out a
couple years ago called make it stick
from Harvard University Press three
authors they talk about desirable
difficulties in this book because it's
so powerful here's what desirable
difficulties can do if I give all of you
a paragraph about jellyfish and half of
you have a paragraph that's easy to read
the text is really clear the words you
don't have to look them up it's all in
language you can understand and half of
you have a piece of paper that's
difficult to read maybe some of the
letters are reversed maybe some of the
words are more difficult than you have
to look them up but essentially the
information is the same and I say in
five minutes I'm gonna give you a quiz
on this paragraph on jellyfish you
people over here who have the difficult
to read piece of paper you are going to
slay them on the quiz in the short term
and then in the long term if you all
come back and take this quiz again in
like two weeks you're really gonna kill
them on the quiz because what your brain
has done when you had to work a little
bit harder to get information in your
brain said oh this is not short term
memory stuff short term memory
is like the number for the pizza guy
something that you can like keep in your
head for a second but then it's fine it
can go away when you have to work a
little bit harder to get the information
in your head your brain says oh no this
is long-term memory stuff clearly this
is important this is more challenging it
causes the brain automatically to do
this thing called encoding where it
takes the information moves it from
short-term to long-term memory
short-term memory is not a place where
we can manipulate information very well
and it's definitely not a place where we
store stuff long-term so if we want kids
to do oh I don't know no information
well enough to be able to apply it in a
novel situation it needs to be in long
term it can't just be sitting in
short-term and what you people did over
here to learn about the jellyfish was
you you crammed you heard you had five
minutes to learn it all and so you just
shoved it in your head maybe those of
you brought highlighters with you you
highlighted please let's take
highlighters away from kids because all
they do is highlight everything and they
say that's okay I'll memorize all of it
that's cramming those of us who have
done any amount of cramming in our lives
no it does not work it definitely
doesn't work over the short-term it
really doesn't work over the long-term
you know those of us who cram we try to
shove it all in there stick a cork in
our ear and then like walk this way to
the test so it doesn't all dribble out
some fun information when I get when I
get to talk to kids I talked to them a
lot about sleep and the importance of
sleep because I cannot i can't
overestimate the importance of sleep one
of the pieces of information I give them
as there are studies that have shown
that if you have one hour you know your
kids like a one more hour I'll turn the
lights off in one more hour I just want
to do one more hour studying and you're
like oh my kid is so diligent and
fantastic what you can tell your child
is one extra hour of sleep is more
powerful because of the memory
consolidation then one more hour of
studying so please when I tell kids how
much sleep they're supposed to be
getting they just laugh I mean there's
teenagers supposed to still be getting
around nine and a half hours of sleep a
night and they're getting nowhere near
that a lot of kids are getting somewhere
closer to six and a half and in terms of
learning that it's sleep sleep is one of
the most important things we can
do so tell your kid if they say I want
one more hour say look how you learned
from this woman mr. Lahey she's an
education researcher and she found out
that one more hour of sleep is more
valuable than nah and that's why the
American Academy of Pediatrics came to
came together a couple years ago to
issue a statement saying that schools
should open no earlier than 8:30 in the
morning because an extra hour of sleep
is such a powerful thing for teenagers
just on the on a little tangent if your
teenagers say late at night I'm just not
sleepy yet they're not lying they really
aren't
teenagers have this thing called sleep
phase delay where their brain squirts
out melatonin and other chemicals and
makes them sleepy later but the other
problem is that that one of the other
things that teenagers brains don't do
very well is perceive how tired they are
so they could be exhausted and they're
not as good as adults are at knowing
that which is why you know I have to tap
on their shoulder when they're drooling
on the desk it's also why when schools
do move their school start times later
an hour later not only does it improve
test scores grades behavior it decreases
the number of car accidents caused by
children caused by teenagers an hour and
extra hour sleep is incredibly powerful
thing really really powerful okay and by
the way if you can get the American
Academy of Pediatrics to come together
and issue a policy statement on
something it's kind of sort of a miracle
and it really means that they're serious
so when they come out and say schools
should start no earlier than 8:30 for
high school this is not for younger kids
because they don't have the sleep phase
delay issue but for high school it's
it's important stuff it's really worth
listening and yes it's incredibly
difficult to move school start times
because of sports and extracurriculars
it really seems to be worth it in the
school districts that have done it okay
autonomy still over here incompetence
the difference between competence and
confidence is really important to know
confidence is that empty feeling of yeah
I'm telling me all the time how smart I
am it's gonna be fine it'll be great or
that kid who comes to kindergarten and
says I'm here and I'm the best reader in
the class because my parents told me so
that's that's sort of that's great
optimism
is fantastic I am an optimistic person I
think it's what keeps me from just
falling down with despair over you know
the state of education some days but it
needs to be paired with experience and
competence is confidence paired with
actual experience doing something
screwing it up figuring out what to
leave behind and what to bring forward
with you and trying and doing it again I
I got to work on this really fun
television show for four really young
kids called the stinky and dirty show it
runs on Amazon and in that show we have
these two characters who have to get
these tasks done and inevitably their
first sort of ideas about how they're
gonna get these tasks done or classic
like preschooler tat like well wait for
the moon to come up and then we'll throw
a lasso over the moon and it'll pull the
bowling ball up or whatever and you know
they come to find that that's not gonna
work but they don't say well that's it
I'm too stupid to do this they come up
with it because they're supportive of
each other and because they are working
for it toward a common goal and because
they're resilient little creatures
little characters they're a dump truck
and a digger they move forward with the
next iteration of the plan
that's competence in the classroom it
looks like this I give kids something
let's say we're in Latin class sorry if
I give anyone flashbacks and I'm
teaching the nominative in the
accusative case and I say okay here's
this sentence puella quarum amat the
girl loves the boy standard word order
in Latin and they get kind of
comfortable with that and then I go over
here and I say okay this one's a little
harder prayer room pull up I'm not and
they freaked out at first they're like
that makes no sense you know um is in
the wrong place and then they calm down
and I say no no you have the skills to
do this just be quiet for a second in my
classroom you're not allowed to speak
for a few seconds after I present a
question because that sort of favors the
extroverts who throw their hands up in
the air and they're like and they don't
know what they're gonna say they have no
idea but you got to sort of let the I
know because I'm one of those in law
school I figured as my hand was up in
the air something would fall out of my
mouth that made sense and plus if I
volunteered enough that
mean that maybe I wouldn't get called on
like randomly totally works
but introverted kids often in the
classroom need a few more moments to
think and so I that was a big discovery
I made as a teacher is that if I stopped
calling on kids right away I could
actually level the playing field a bit
so the problem with these kids is then
they say oh I don't know that's so hard
but then they realize okay no no I did
it this way over here mrs. Lahey has
faith in me she thinks I can do it oh I
see what you did you just reversed the
two words I got it
and then I give them something even
harder and whether that's in the form of
homework and I do not have time to talk
about the way I feel about homework I've
written about it extensively at the New
York Times in the Atlantic the research
is pretty clear I don't have time to
talk about that but if I give them let's
say homework that's builds on what we
did in class but is a little bit harder
incorporating I don't know some of those
desirable difficulties in I need the
kids to be able to stay calm and realize
that they tend to trust that I'm not
just putting them out there with this
difficult stuff that they can't possibly
do and it's the kids who can be
frustrated who can push through it's the
kids who feel competent not just
confident the confidence game you know
really comes out of it self-esteem
movement total failure by the way
self-esteem movement what we hoped was
that if we told our kids enough times
how fantastic and wonderful and gifted
and talented they are that they would
have this like Star Wars forcefield of
wonderfulness around them so that when
they would go off to school and if
someone said something mean it would
like people wouldn't go off the side and
but they would come home with like this
their force field of wonderfulness
intact it doesn't work that way the
research on self-esteem and praise shows
there is a study that came out just
recently was really interesting it
showed that for kids who have really low
self-esteem
the kids we really need to boy up with
our words of support and praise if we
tell those kids that they're so smart
gifted talented perfect we don't raise
their self-esteem we low
it because for kids like that and I
often remember myself sitting there in
Algebra one thinking oh my gosh I'm the
only person who does not understand any
of this
and my if I had gone home and my parents
were telling me constantly how gifted I
was my school reality and home reality
would not match and that is really
disturbing to kids when I speak to kids
one of my favorite grades to speak to a
sixth-grade because they have the best
questions and recently I was at a school
in New York and this one kid raised his
hand and he said yeah I don't know if
this is just me or not but my parents
tell me I am perfect like everything I
do and I just don't think that can be
right and I said it's not just you
sweetie and and as wonderful as as I
think I assume you are it's probably
true that you're not perfect at
everything and that's good because we
shouldn't be perfect at everything right
off the bat that means we're probably
not trying very hard and so telling kids
how wonderful and perfect they are all
the time can mess with their heads not
only that those of you who are familiar
at all with Carol Dweck and her work on
mindsets if you've only read articles
about Carol Dweck and mindsets I would
encourage you to read the whole book
because the way journalism tends I hope
this doesn't come as a shocker to anyone
but what often happens is I go to my
editor and I say I have this article I
want to write on this amazing
breakthrough education theory and I'm
gonna need like two thousand words and
she's like okay sounds great you can
write it but you get 500 words so we
tend to oversimplify just because that's
how they're all terribly editors are
terribly concerned that your attention
span is about this big so we need to
prove them wrong so I go off and I have
to write about something you know making
a list which is ridiculous those of you
who have been only read about Carol
Dweck's research what you probably think
it means is that we should only praise
our children for their effort and never
tell them that they're smart which is
stupid because if I were to run at that
door and I don't know that I have to
press that bar right there to make the
door
unlatch but I just keep running at the
door and bashing my body against it and
you keep saying oh just good effort keep
going
you are terrible teachers I'm not
learning very much I'm not gonna trust
you anymore we're sort of neither one of
us is getting anywhere but if you're
supportive in a way that a lot of
teachers know works pretty well in the
classroom is oh I see you're having some
problems stop for a second look at the
door is there anything you're not
thinking of is there anything you
haven't considered that's what great
teaching and parenting looks like
because that allows the child to have
some autonomy over their learning and
figure out you know oh what am I not
thinking about so competence over
confidence one of the ways we can do
that is by praising them for the process
part talking a lot about the process as
opposed to the end product Carol Dweck's
research is really interesting here's a
quick primer she gives a math a math
quiz to everyone let's say this is a
math quiz for all of you and it's right
in your sweet spot it's not gonna be too
hard or too easy to half of you she
comes back and her praise is Oh sweetie
you got an 8 out of 10 you must be so
smart and then the other half she says
oh you got an 8 out of 10 you must have
worked so hard and then she gives all of
the kids a slightly harder quiz and when
the results come in the kids who have
been praised for how smart they are do
the same or a little bit worse which
it's a harder quiz of course the kids
who've been praised for how hard they
work do the same or a little bit better
which is interesting to me as a teacher
but not as interesting as this because
then she says thank you so much for
being a part of this today now before
you go I have these challenge questions
they're hard you may not be able to do
all of them who who wants them
the kids who are praised for how smart
they are want nothing to do with the
challenge problems however the kids who
are praised for how hard they worked
want the challenge problems in fact one
girl in the experiment said well of
course we want the challenge problems
those are the fun ones those are the
ones we have to work out again I come
back to this discussion of desirable
difficulties if you people don't want
the challenge problems you're probably
not stretching yourself and learning as
well then here
so that's interesting but again I'm
really really interested in how we can
create learning environments that are
not conducive to cheating that kids
don't feel like they have to cheat in
I'm really fascinated by academic
dishonesty and how we can fix that
here's what I love is then I say Ms
Carol Dweck says I love pretending to be
Carol Dweck she says now before you go
if everyone could flip over their piece
of paper I'm gonna give this quiz at
another school and if you could flip
over your piece of paper and write down
your experience of taking this quiz and
what your score was that would be really
helpful for those other kids new people
over here who appraised for your effort
how hard you worked you wrote down your
experience and you wrote down your quiz
score almost 50% of you people who were
praised for how smart you are
lied about your score and artificially
inflated it when I ask kids again with
those sixth graders but I've asked this
question to kids as young as
fourth-grade why do you think the kids
who were praised for being smart don't
want the challenge problems and lie
about their scores and they're like well
duh if you've told us that you're smart
we're not gonna screw that up we need
for you to keep believing that we need
the kids around us our friends to keep
believing that and that means that
everything has to look easy and if we
take the challenge problems we're
probably gonna get some wrong and you're
not gonna think we're smart anymore and
if other people are gonna know about our
quizzes well we're gonna lie a little
bit and say that we got a higher score
than we did James M lang who wrote a
book called cheating lessons about
creating learning environments where
kids don't need to cheat said it's
really clear if you want to create a
classroom full of cheaters just keep
telling them how smart they are I don't
think it's quite that simple the rest of
the book goes on to explain how the way
we assess kids right now is probably not
the best way to do it and again I don't
have time to talk about how I feel about
grading and how I feel about various
forms of assessment I have written about
it extensively at the Atlantic in the
New York Times you can go find it and
the piece of the Atlantic is called why
letter grades deserve an F it turns out
they're not the way we test kids
doesn't tend to work very well for
learning anyway okay autonomy competence
connection again for teachers this all
comes down to relevance this all comes
down to that teacher who's you know
sometimes these teachers have these you
can't put your finger on it you don't
know what exactly it is but they make
learning come alive that teacher comes
in and says I found out last night that
there was an earthquake in Peru and so
let me show you some pictures of the
bridges that fell down and the bridges
that stayed up and let's see what we can
what we can sort of gather from looking
at these two different kinds of bridges
and okay here are some bridges over here
that fell down and oh my gosh they're
all rectangles and look at these bridges
over here that are arches those are
still standing and this is geometry
class and did you know that the people
who built those bridges were once kids
just like you who sat in these geometry
classes and found out about things like
the Roman aqueducts where the arches are
what have kept them standing for
thousands of years and why this kind of
bridge over here is likely not to work
and those kids not only learn about
shapes that work in geometry and how why
those shapes work but what they also
learn is oh my gosh I could do that I
could build bridges that will hold up
when there's an earthquake that's called
that's called self-efficacy there's
self-efficacy is an incredibly important
element of any education program which
is knowing that not only do you have the
ability to change your own life to that
the decisions you make will make a
difference it's why kids who are in
really traumatic situations as children
children who live in abuse children who
live with people who are drug and
alcohol addicted they learn that there's
not a lot they can do to change their
environment they lose their sense of
self-efficacy and that's a disaster not
just for their lives but for their
learning it's one of the many reasons
that kids who have experienced trauma at
a young age just don't learn as well not
only that one of the things we know
about learning is that the very fastest
way to interrupt learning is to
introduce stress it's why often at the
end of the
talks I'll get a question about the
impact of competition on children and
learning and I have to say that's a very
complicated question because it turns
out for some kids it's helpful
competition for some kids is fantastic
it can lead to better learning everyone
can lead to higher achievement but for
some kids it's a disaster because you
could have a kid who knows their their
multiplication tables really really well
and the second you say this is a timed
worksheet they fall apart it's why Joe
bowler who wrote the book mathematical
mindsets says the very first thing we
need to do if we really want to teach
math effectively in this country is stop
timing worksheets because mastery and
being able to do math fast are not the
same thing and it's creates a lot of
math anxiety and that comes as a person
who had for much of my life very really
really horrible math anxiety I was told
in seventh grade that I wasn't a math
person so when I went back to take
algebra 1 again when I was 45 because
one of my friends was teaching the class
and it was right next to where my office
was and I told you about all that free
time I had when I was a middle school
teacher yeah I tossed that one prep
period and I sat in on her class and I
took algebra one at the same time my
older son took Algebra one we took it
together and I took it with my students
and I learned that I'm I'm not bad at
math math is hard math is challenging
and so one of the things that happens in
this competence confidence area is we
have these kids we tell them early on in
their lives you were born good at math
you're just so great at math and what
happens to these kids is that they boot
they start to believe that it's always
supposed to be easy for them because if
it's not easy for them then maybe they
aren't as smart as we're telling them
they are when I went back and took
retook math in my 40s Algebra one in my
40s my mentor for that with Steven
Strogatz who's a math professor at
Cornell and he says one of the things he
says is you know we got to stop telling
kids that they're just good at math
because what's good math get will get
hard for everyone
otherwise we wouldn't have proofs that
we can't solve out there we wouldn't
have had firm up plus
I'm sitting around for as long as we did
for those kids but those kids who are
told that they're just good at math you
know they're gonna be just good at math
for a little while and it's gonna be
going great and they're gonna be doing
really really well and then it's going
to get hard for them whether that's in
sixth grade or tenth grade or freshman
year of college just happens to a lot of
kids how they respond to that when it
does get challenging is is everything
that determines how well they're going
to do over time there is no there's a
lot of kids actually who hit that moment
and just drop it and say oh I this was
all imposter syndrome this was all a big
mistake and I wasn't really ever as
smart as I thought I was so for teachers
this relevant stuff is like
multi-layered and amazing and again if
your kids have teachers that are making
learning relevant and making kids feel
like they have self-efficacy I love
those teachers up there just fantastic
for parents it's really really simple
connection for parents comes down to two
things you have to love the child you
have not the child you wish you had not
some fantasy of the child that they you
developed based on all the things you
wish you had done oh if I had just
practiced piano I could be so good now
so I'm gonna sit on my kid and make them
practice piano all of those fantasies
you have about who your child could be
may not be the child that's sitting
right in front of you and our kids know
it when we're not loving them when we
don't see them so love the kid you have
not the kid you wish you had and don't
just love your kid based on their
performance and I know I'm like I would
never do that except when they come home
with a test that they're really excited
to show us they're like show it to us
and it's an A and we flip out we're like
blur on Instagram and put it on Facebook
and let's live tweet a blue know that
and you freak out they they're getting
the message that oh here we go I'm
giving them the good stuff the stuff
they love but then they come home a
little more sedate with with the F I'm
sorry B - that's what we call an F now
right
okay so with that F or B - and we show
it they show it to us and we're silent
that's silenced by the way when I talked
to kids I make it really clear that this
parenting thing is so important to us
that we have to like look for just the
right words to say just the right thing
but ask any psychologist that silence
that's withdrawal of love based on
performance and it's one of the most
emotionally devastating things we can do
to kids and lest you think that you
would never like I did remember when I
asked those kids how many of you believe
that your parents love you more when you
bring them the grades and scores that
you they want versus the ones they don't
and then you get those eighty to ninety
percent I mean I think it's lower for
middle school because I think middle
school kids still have some face they're
still there's still like old they're
trying to do the right things I can tell
and it's the reason also that the heart
of the gift of failure is is on middle
school because really that's our moment
to really allow them to make mistakes
and allow them to learn from those
mistakes so autonomy competence and
connection those are the three pieces
that we need to bring together in some
way and I'm I don't want to go too long
today and I want to leave plenty of time
for questions but bringing that together
is a really amazing thing so I get I'm
so fortunate I get a lot of letters from
parents and I love all of them and most
of them say things like oh you were so
right I let my kid you know put her
dishes in the dishwasher and she was so
proud of herself and she's becoming more
and more competent and I love those
letters I love them but I love these
even more the ones that I get that says
you know what I gave my kid more
autonomy I sort of said you know sweetie
I think I've been doing too much for you
and I I actually think you're able to do
much more than I give you credit for so
this is now going to be your thing and
usually that's homework homework is a
good place to start this is your thing
now I'm not going to be checking the
portal I'm not gonna be sitting right
there with you while you do your
homework because I have faith that this
is your thing and then talking really
really clearly about your expectations
and your
secuence around homework expectations
could be you know for us was for a long
time it was just you'll do your homework
until we realized that he was doing his
homework this is Finn I'm talking about
cuz his stories in the book he was doing
his homework he just wasn't getting the
homework into the backpack and taking
the homework out of the backpack so this
was you know our expectations in our and
our strategies had to shift and then
making the consequences really really
clear about what will happen if they're
not meeting those expectations and by
the way our consequences that we tend to
come up with as adults make perfect
sense to us sometimes or don't make any
sense to kids kids younger kids in
particular their frontal lobe our
frontal lobe is the last part of our
brain to fully cook and that's where all
the organization the executive function
you know time management organization of
all that stuff the locker and the
classes and the notebooks and keeping
the pants up and tying the shoes all
that stuff happens in executive function
and executive function our frontal lobe
is not fully cooked until we're in our
early 20s I used to say yeah you can
just wait until your kid's brain is
fully baked and then I realized that
cooked maybe works better because fully
baked just has the wrong connotation
about it but waiting until their brain
you know sometimes there are just places
in life like middle school where we're
asking them to do way more than their
brain can actually handle witches as I
come back to the magic of middle school
because my job is to watch kids screw up
all day long and help them come up with
strategies to fix them and any time
those moments are stolen that's really
difficult for them and for us
autonomy competence connection because
that connection part here's what can
happen when we do give our kids more
autonomy let's say around homework and
we back off the letters then that I get
are not just my kid has become more
competent which I love but our
relationship has improved we talk about
stuff that matters not just the stuff
that I want to talk about when I sat in
recently on a panel of freshmen a sorry
of seniors in high school who were
giving advice to parents of incoming
freshmen one of the
parents said what's the biggest pity the
most important piece of advice that you
could give us about how to help our kids
have a good first year in high school
and the kids said stop talking to them
about grades every minute of the day
they know grades are important maybe and
in the book I talked about a possible
alternative maybe we could talk to them
about their goals maybe we could talk to
them about what they love what they're
interested in talk to them about what
their personal goals are for school as
opposed to what you know what their
grades are that day because then when
you get into that stuff that's when you
get to really know your kids you get to
know the kid that's in front of you the
kid your kid not that fantasy kid you
wish you had that's what sort of allows
kids to feel like they can trust us to
have conversations that are a little bit
difficult about maybe where they screwed
up because they know that we're not just
loving them based on performance we're
loving them because we love them and
that we support them alright I'm gonna
stop there because I could keep going on
for hours but I'm assuming they're
questions I happen to know there are
some questions before I even came into
this on YouTube I have a series called
gift of failure FAQs frequently asked
questions answering the most common
questions I get via email so they're
like how to help kids who Coast how to
help perfectionist kid how to parent
perfectionist kids what about my special
needs kid does that is there a different
message there should I feel stupid for
trusting the school when they told me
what I really need to focus on is grades
and points and scores really it's called
should I feel stupid for being duped by
a flawed system there are a lot of flaws
with our education system right now and
you know I couldn't write a book that
upended all of that I had to say here's
what we've got right now how do we work
within that so focusing you know for
example on goals as opposed to grades is
a great place to start but I'm happy to
take any questions what if I told you I
know what your questions are someone's
gonna ask me about musical instruments
and when they're allowed to let their
kid quit that's one - I get that one a
lot my kid has been playing soccer since
she was six and now she's 14 and she's
really really really good but she says
she doesn't want to play soccer anymore
what should i do should I let her
that's a question I get a lot what's the
answer
um it honestly certain certain things
we're talking about whether that's music
or athletics really depends on your
priorities as a family often this
question is about sports or music and so
I'll use those two examples in my home
we're not we like music but we are not
an intensely musical family a friend of
mine who has a very musical family it is
a non-negotiable that their children
will play some instrument until they are
18 that's just a non-negotiable it's
it's not going any other way so for them
quitting an instrument means fine what
are you going to take up next at which
point the child says oh yeah no I've
already been doing the cello for a while
I guess I'll just stick with that in our
house I tell a story often my son his
older brother I would our neighbor next
door neighbor had a piano that they were
getting rid of and I'm like perfect
because I've read the research showing
that if your kid can do music that
they're gonna be better at math and so I
really need to do the music thing in the
math piano that's perfect
and so we wheeled the piano down from
their house into our house and we got
him lessons and we had the honeymoon
period you know where it's all great for
like a week maybe two weeks and then it
was fighting constantly constantly you
have to practice here's what you need to
practice how are you gonna practice what
do you know have you practiced yet and
it was really undermining our
relationship and for me and
non-negotiable is our relationship and
so and for me whether or not he plays
piano honestly I could care less
really and truly so we wheeled the piano
down the street to the next suckers
house and it can only go downhill and
we're on it
we're on a big hill so it came down and
then it went down to my hat my friend
Vicki's house and then it went down from
their house down but then what was
really interesting is a couple years
later my husband plays guitar and my
older son saw my husband playing guitar
and said you know I think I might want
to do some guitars so he took some
lessons he learned out very quickly that
it wasn't the piano or the guitar that
he was not enjoying it was the lesson
for Matt he just doesn't like having
someone else tell him what he has to
play and when so he doesn't liked anyone
telling him what he has to do ever so it
turns out there's plenty of ways you can
learn online by yourself there's Jam
play you pay little pay like a hundred
and something bucks and you get to
choose your instructor and choose
your lessons and you can repeat them or
fast-forward or whatever or YouTube's
another place you can do that and he
became a really really good guitar
player and of course I kept my hands way
off of that because as soon as my mom
stink was on any aspect of the guitar
playing it was over for him the minute I
messed with his autonomy and his control
over this learning guitar thing done I
was able to sort of encourage him to you
know have you listened to Eric Clapton
yet you know that kind of stuff and then
what was really interesting is after
he's been playing guitar for about a
year and it really was feeling confident
he sheepishly came to me and he said you
know that listserv we have in town where
people self use stuff like it if anyone
had a keyboard you know I might be
interested in learning piano and I was
able to find a keyboard on our listserv
I paid like a hundred bucks for it and
he taught himself piano in the same way
he taught himself guitar and I really
believe that he is a better musician
than he ever would have been if I had
sat there and forced him you know but
that's priorities in my house same thing
with athletics if you know if your
priority is is sports and you're a very
sports oriented family then you're you
know quitting but then again my other
response is childhood isn't supposed to
be a time when we get to try lots of
different things in my house you know
the kids can take lessons in whatever
they want any time my younger son just
took lessons in welding a couple
weekends ago and now thinks he might
want to try hot and cold forging because
that could be really interesting and
luckily we have a place nearby that will
teach them teens that but if you have a
kid who's 14 who every moment there is
taken up with playing soccer that
they've been playing since they were six
and they really really hate it what are
they not getting an opportunity to try
we tend to think that you know we'll be
raising quitters if we let them quit but
you can't know if you like or don't like
something until you have tried it so
trying something in the deciding it's
not for you is not quitting that's
knowing about yourself and going on to
something else that might be more fun
and often the answer I'll get from
parents's but we have so much invested
in soccer and I just want to say what's
the return on this investment you're
hoping for
like there's a great New York Times
headline a while back that said your kid
is not gonna play professional sports
now what like know what your goals are
going into this and that's one reason
the sports chapter was so fun to write
there was one study showing that it was
a small informal an informal study but
of lots of kids where this guy said
what's your favorite thing about youth
sports and what was your least favorite
thing about youth sports he asked
serious athletes about this and they
said my least favorite thing about youth
sports was the ride home in the car with
my parents after games now I don't know
about you a lot of good talking happens
in the car and the idea that that would
be the worst thing about youth sports
gives me headaches and their favorite
thing about youth sports was when their
grandparents came to watch them play
because the grandparents don't care what
the score is the grandparents are in it
to watch the kid play one of my favorite
websites out there about being a good
sports parent is called I love to watch
you play calm because that's really in
the end for many kids what it's all
about and that's why I get to spend a
lot of time on sports podcasts and
things like that did you have a question
yes well I should mention now from
whatever nutso reason and I apologize
there aren't books here today that was a
mistake on my part
um I'm misunderstanding but at Amazon
right now it's four dollars and 52 cents
I can't get them that cheaply so we like
and you can only order four so like all
of my friends order books and bring them
to my house at four dollars and fifty
two cents oh yeah 452 at em yeah because
my question is I elementary school and
we have a science project that was due
today one pair of me yeah watch the kid
do things and then my wife just jumps in
yeah it starts doing my things but then
I'm also the one that ended exercise
appraises oh that's amazing oh this is
gonna be still you're so amazing and
everything yeah how is instead of like
what you need to do with your kid yeah
what advice do you have for parents with
okay so what this really comes down to
is like there are these big takeaways
and on the bookmark my son gave you
there's some takeaways one of the
biggest takeaways like the fastest way
to switch your thinking right now is to
be thinking long term about what you
want for your kids so do you want this
science project right here to be perfect
or do you want your kid next year when
the science fair rolls around to not be
doing it the night before so real live
story Finnegan another authorized story
Finnegan had a science fair project that
he so half-assed it wasn't even
half-assed it was like a sliver asked
and it was it came down to a piece of
trifold with some Sharpie you know big
stars and you know filling up space over
here look over here you know that kind
of thing and then he had to go to the
science fair and sit there and defend
his project for two hours and you know
next to the girl who has the like
life-sized hologram of the union you
know it's a scale hologram of the
universe that she totally did herself of
course not but that was an incredibly
important lesson right sitting to having
to sit there in front of something you
created or didn't create and defend it
is a really tough thing to do but it's
also an incredible learning experience
because the next time he had to do a
science project and do you know which
one I'm talking about sweetie
now he's listening to headphones this do
you know which science project I'm
talking about that was the killer one
the greys one the one with alien yeah it
was really really good so I didn't even
get to see that project until it was
ready to go to the science fair and it
it was so it was so far beyond what I
thought my kid was capable of simply
because he's like well I'm not doing
what I did last time and sitting there
and being humiliated because that wasn't
fun
no it wasn't fun but it was incredibly
good learning experience so good
thinking long term instead short term my
kid can do acts today but where do I
want them to be in six months and a year
whatever you can even think in terms of
my kid's gonna go off to college when
they're 18 what do I need them to be
able to do make a checklist they're
great checklists out there my friend
julilah Scott Hanes has a book called
to raise an adult she's got checklists I
have checklists in the book
age-appropriate checklist of what kids
are actually capable of doing that we
don't ever ask them to do because we're
like well of course they can't do that
that's that requires too much whatever
long-term instead of short-term is the
most important thing and process instead
of product I mean if you come down to
the fact that the doing for all good
projects at school really the doing of
the project should always be far more
important than whatever the end product
is it just so happens that you know kids
do like creating an end product so
that's a great way to sort of show
something off at the end focus on
process over product focus on you know
the parts that are difficult for them
saying I'm really proud of you for
sticking with that when that I saw how
hard that was for you long division
maybe is something that's really hard
for you and you know what I'm I watched
you do your homework because you thought
I was just cooking over here but I was
peeking every once in a while and I saw
that number three just gave you fits but
you know what you you went on to four
and you came back to three and I'm
really proud of you for that
that's praising for effort that's
constructive praise for effort but that
long term over short term man that only
works for our kids it works for us it
works for all kinds of stuff because we
tend to parent in emergency mode this
homework has to be perfect the kid
doesn't have lunch today will she
survive yes she will survive the fastest
way I tell schools if they they say this
is all well and good how do we send a
message really really quickly to the
entire community that we care more about
the process than the product that we
care more about the whole child than the
grades I say one of the great things
that schools have been doing
increasingly around the country is
making a rule that there's no dropping
forgotten stuff off after first Bell not
only is that sending the message that
what you really care about is that the
kid learns to manage their time and
learns how to use their plan book and
and can cope with the consequences of
their actions but it's also fair if you
think about who can afford to bring
stuff to school late it's certainly not
people who do shift work or rely on
public transportations so from an equity
quality perspective um it tends to be a
really great thing for the school
district so that's my recommendation to
schools is that rule works wonders
actually
it's stepping away stepping away it's
also what works when other parents are
going nuts and they're like and we do
cello and we have all this tutoring and
he's on the traveling soccer league and
you start to hyperventilate I wrote an
article for The Atlantic called why
back-to-school night made me feel like a
bad parent step away we are each other's
worst enemy when it comes to that stuff
so step away and if you have to go I
totally get it
bibliography is that Jessica Lahey calm
there's a newsletter that if you sign up
on my website there's a newsletter with
all the links to everything plus there's
a new like book discussion group guide
that has questions for each chapter and
stuff like that and the bibliography and
all that fun stuff ok sorry yeah so
that's tough so often our consequences
tend to be extrinsic right punishment or
you know I'm going to take that thing
away from you especially take that thing
away from you we tend to say we're gonna
take those electronics away from you
because in our adult brain that makes so
much sense right because we're killing
two birds with one stone not only will
they be bummed out and not want to lose
their electronics but if they lose their
electronics they will have more time to
work on their homework it's so brilliant
except for the fact that for kids whose
frontal lobes aren't fully cooked it
makes no sense it's like saying if you
can't build this house this treehouse
I'm gonna send you to Mars because
electronics and if you think about it
normally what we're saying is if now
okay so this is September April
September if in December your grade
falls we're gonna take away your
electronics and you have a kid let's say
a middle school kid who's focused on
this homework assignment should I really
put in my all on this homework
assignment they are very bad at saying
this homework assignment is related to
this thing over here in December that's
totally unrelated to school my
electronics those two things don't
equate so the closer you can make
consequences to the actual consequences
that happen when a kid doesn't do
something so for example with homework
the classic in our house anyway would be
if you don't get your homework in to the
teacher and it becomes a thing like at
once always happens you know that that's
a process of learning then you will lead
the parent-teacher Kid conference where
we talk about how we can best help you
where we can talk about strategy we're
not gonna leave that you are because
you're the one who's forgetting your
homework so you have to set that meeting
up and you have to make it happen
you can work beside I hide this behind
the scenes to kind of pull some strings
so you can email the teacher and say my
kid's gonna come up to you today and ask
you to make an appointment and if that
doesn't happen could you let me know or
could you sort of engineer a moment
where it might be easier for the kid to
ask that I do that as a teacher all the
time parents will get in touch with me
and say she really needs to talk to you
about something she's upset about and I
have a feeling she's not going to so
could you kind of make an opportune
moment for that that's really helpful
for us by the way those of you help your
kids with homework homework is
information for us so a classic in math
class a friend of mine talks about this
all the time that she'll have in algebra
1 she'll get homework back that uses
trigonometry to figure something out and
she'll ask the kids so how did you
arrive at this answer and the kids like
and it's pretty clear that you know the
kid hasn't been doing the work and and
you know whatever except for the fact
that now the teacher can't tell what the
kid can and can't do so the more
information for the more opportunities
for information the better so
consequences really should as best you
can make them flow from whatever it was
the kid didn't do a friend of mine at
the end of the book inevitably someone
asked the question of well what about
real failure like falling failing out of
school failure there's a story at the
end of the book about that someone whose
son was failing out of school because he
refused to sort of take command of the
situation and work she and I talked
about getting a probationary semester
for her son she negotiated this
probationary semester before they kicked
him out cuz she got really lucky there
then she had to say to her son you have
this probationary semester so you're
gonna go for a couple days to this other
school which is where you'll have to go
to school if you funk out of this school
and it was not a great choice for him it
was not a really great school for him to
go to and he attended that other school
for the day and he came home and he's
like okay I'm in what do I have to do
and she said well you should also know
that I'm not gonna be completing stuff
for you anymore this is you this is your
education this is your decision you had
we need buy-in from you he still talks
about that moment the kid I kept in
touch with the parent the kid as being
the turning point in his life and i am i
get to report this because it she just
found out recently he's going to college
now on full scholarship he not only took
control of his education completely
turned it around and by the way when a
kid turns around education that's when
we get to write the really good letters
of recommendation the kids who have just
been sort of coasting or kids who just
sort of you know have been perfect all
along those letters are whatever they're
fun fine but the letters of kids who
really have sort of taken that
opportunity to change to like who get
inspired and decide to change things
those are the letters that get them into
college and that's what happened with
this kid he had more scholarships to
choose from then you know then he knew
what to do with and so he's going to
college for free the college his dream
college and and really because he nearly
failed out so he has a story to tell
about his transcript you know he was
able to say look you look at my
transcript and you think I really was
falling apart freshman year and let me
tell you that story and let me tell you
where I am now as a human being because
of that story he had to suffer the real
consequences and if he had you know if
he had failed out of school that I know
for a fact his mother would have taken
him and put him in that other school and
he would have had to sink or swim there
it ended up being a fantastic
opportunity for him and maybe even an
opportunity for him to realize that
wasn't what he wanted and find out if
there would be a way that he could work
his way back into the other school
that's always a possibility to yes
behind you yeah yeah sorry I haven't
even by the way till 1:30 but
I'm happy to stick around and answer
questions as long as I help I'm not
going anywhere I totally understand as
parents like not wanting to be
controlled in /cam erectus I happen to
have my oldest one of the sixth grade
mm-hmm and he he just really doesn't
work hard when it comes to school right
he's very bright if that means he can
not work hard on this assignment or not
very much for this mess and he gets a B
he is fine with that
yep I'm not fine right now because I
know you put zero effort into that play
right and this is a constant argument
yeah with us and it's also what are you
doing okay so number one if you want
like a really thorough 15 minute long
answer it's at the gift of failure facts
how how to motivate kids who Coast what
you also need to know from a
developmental perspective is this until
you get to middle school like sixth
grade seventh grade eighth grade really
the end of fifth grade kids are really
focused internally and they're really
focused on getting your love and
approval they're really focused on how
you're reacting to what they're doing
fifth grade sixth grade seventh grade
suddenly the world opens up the social
life opens up and hormones start to kick
in and oh my gosh people are looking at
me and all oh my gosh that the big joke
in middle school is that all middle
schoolers believe that everyone is
looking at them all the time which means
that they have to be focused on
themselves and everyone is so focused on
themselves actually looking at each
other so they're you know more outwardly
focused and friendships tend to become
more outwardly focused and so they
become that takes front-seat for a
little while and understanding that is
gonna go a long way towards helping you
understand the motivation at least
understanding why your kid may be
pulling back from the school stuff which
may be the year before he was all over
that so understanding motivation is
really really important because that
helps you understand where your fulcrum
point is where those levers can get you
know installed and knowing what their
goals are is going to be really
important you know you could talk to you
if you happen to know that your kid
wants to get into a certain math class
the next year or your kid wants to go to
a certain
your kid wants to do a certain thing for
work one of the things like it kid says
I really want to be a architect I don't
know whatever you can talk to them about
the fact that well how do you plan to
get there one of the things I do a lot
as an advisor to two kids is not just
talk about what their long-term goals
are because well that's all well and
good talking to them about the the goals
the short-term achievable goals they
have to get through to get to those
long-term goals that's called
self-directed executive function when
they can come up with those intermediary
steps to get to the big goal out there
it can be less threatening to talk about
these short-term goals than that big one
out there and it's also more about
process than product so if you can if
you happen to know that your kid really
wants to play soccer but you have to
have a C or better to play soccer
then there's your fulcrum point if you
happen to know that your kid wants to go
to this high school as opposed to that
one but this high school is a little bit
harder to get into then you can know
well that's your fulcrum point if you
really want to be over there let's talk
about your strategies for how to make
that happen
for kids who are coasting honestly the
reaction they're getting out of you for
not sometimes for not putting in that
extra a little bit um
it can also be remember when I talked
about kids not wanting to fail and
that's really scary for them if you're
telling them constantly look we know
you're not working up to your potential
we know you're smarter than this in the
back of the head one of the things the
kids can hear is but what if I'm not and
so going that extra step can be really
scary because that you know what if I'm
not as smart as other people think I am
what if my friends find out what if my
teachers find out so focusing more on
the process rather than that end product
can can sort of help them get over that
the other thing that can help when I go
to talk to kids you can I talk to them
about I look at the audience and I say
if you're coasting and you know who you
are you are not becoming smarter as fast
as your classmates because what we know
about the brain is if you read Carol
Dweck's mindset what we know is that the
harder we push ourselves and this goes
for adults too the more we push
ourselves outside of our comfort zone
like if I were to take I don't know
ballroom dancing
would be a nightmare scenario for me
because I just I'm clumsy but I would be
making connections in my brain I would
become less clumsy if I am not great at
math but I push myself harder in math
I'm learning more because I'm making
more connections in our brain it's sort
of the backwards when we tell older
people to do crossword puzzles so that
they don't lose those connections with
kids the more connections they make the
smarter they will become because that's
how our brains work we're not born with
an IQ number and God forbid if you if
you have to get your kid an IQ test for
some reason and I actually posit that
there's no really good reason to do that
the IQ test was never intended to be a
measure of a numerical measure of
intelligence there's a fantastic book by
Scott Barry Kaufman called ungifted
where he talks about the history of the
IQ test he tells this story through the
lens of a person who was special ed and
now has PhD and works on he works
basically on the neuroscience of
creativity and the psychology of
creativity and what intelligence and
creativity have to do with one another
for example someone with dyslexia may
score lower on a an IQ test but did how
many people in this room know there's an
upside to dyslexia that there are things
people with dyslexia can do that people
without dyslexia can't or at least not
as well yeah some of the most amazing
astronomers we've had in the history of
humankind have been dyslexic because
they have the ability to see sort of
relationships between things and
distance and time in a way that people
who are non dyslexic don't there's a
great book called the upside of dyslexia
by the way that's all about that most IQ
tests don't you know most intelligence
tests don't think take things like
creativity into account or you know your
individual quirks about how you think
and so Scott Barry Kaufman is currently
working to try to come up with a measure
of intelligence that encompasses things
like you know being a people person
being creative person thinking in a way
that's different from your your peers
think so putting as much focus on things
like that and understanding where this
is coming from
and also understanding that your kid
really truly believes because we tend to
talk good game does your kid really
truly believe that what you care about
is learning or you know is it just a lot
of this because if they see us freaking
out over a low grade or going all
effusive and crazy over a high grade but
what we're saying is though it's really
it's learning I care about they they're
more apt to follow sort of they know
that what we really mean is this so I
had a mother recently asked me my kids
they just won't read for fun my son will
not read for fun number one could you
give me a list of really challenging
books that he will want to read for fun
could you do that for me and I was like
that's like a magic list that if you
could come up with that would be great
and I said well I have to start here
first do your children see you read for
fun and the answer is no she had to
admit that she was on time so busy bah
bah bah bah blah and when she did read
she read on a tablet and her kids didn't
know whether she was what she was doing
on that tablet it wasn't clear that she
was reading so if you're not reading I
don't really know how I'm supposed to
help you make it clear to your children
that you think it's an important thing
to do and then I said okay well let's
get back to this magic list what are
your kids like to read and she said well
they really like this one really likes
this Diary of a Wimpy Kid books but I
threw those away because they're stupid
I know for the record when it comes to
literacy the ideal mix of challenge
levels is 30% comfortably below your
reading level 30% at your reading level
I should say a third third and a third
above your reading level this is about
acquiring new vocabulary this is about
strengthening it this is about comfort
and fluency this is about feeling
confident competent feeling it's the
reason why I go back and read things
like little women or Pride and Prejudice
it's the reason kids love repetitive
shows because they take like Blue's
Clues always happens the set I mean it
drives us crazy
but for them it makes them so it makes
them feel like they have mastery because
they know what's coming next and they
can predict what the answer is going to
be and that makes them feel like they're
smart and makes them feel like they're
competent and makes them feel like
they're powerful and that's what reading
stuff that's below their reading level
does well if your kid is in high school
and every once in a while likes to go
back to those copies of whatever that
they read in fifth grade that's great
that is a really productive use of their
time not you know sweetie I know you're
better than those books what you're
saying to them is I think not just that
I think what you love is stupid but I
think you're stupid these choices you're
making or stupid they're by I don't
think as much of you so there's there's
like 16 different things all in one
answer but honestly focusing more on
those sort of the long-term the goals
the levers making sure your kid knows
you're interested in him/her making sure
your kid knows that you really do care
about the learning which means if you're
modeling that you're gonna have to put
yourself out and like try things that
are uncomfortable for you they're gonna
have to see you trying some things that
push you a little bit beyond your
ability level because we can say that
all we want but until they see us take
intellectual and emotional risks they
don't really believe that that's
something worth doing for them that's
why it's so important for teachers to
admit when they don't know the answers
and to say you know what I don't know
let me look that up for you thank you so
so much for being here today I really
appreciate it so much and I'm gonna
stick around and answer questions if
anyone has more if you didn't get a
bookmark or a card or you want to if you
want to get in touch with me the contact
form at my website it's just my email
straight to my email box and I'd be
happy and um for those of you who want a
spouse to sort of hear some of this
because that have thats a question I get
a lot too I will be speaking in a Mercer
Island tomorrow night at the Mercer
Island High School and it's open to the
public
unfortunately the talk I'm giving
tonight is not but the one on Mercer
Island tomorrow is open to the public
and everyone's welcome
thank you very very much
[Applause]